there was a post the other day from one
of these blue check Democrat strategists
who said gosh isn't this amazing the the
two top Republican choices for president
in 2024 Trump and DeSantis are both
under criminal investigation
yeah right exactly funny how that works
they it's it's not that they were under
criminal investigation and now they're
the top picks for the Republicans in
2024 it's the opposite they were the top
guys that is why they're under criminal
investigation and it's not just Trump
it's those two guys Ron DeSantis as well
even Libs even people who appeal
primarily to libs are pointing out Ron
DeSantis is doing a very very good job
positioning himself for the presidential
cycle
for months Republican Governors have
sent busloads of illegal immigrants to
Sanctuary cities like New York DC and
Chicago with the message of if you like
them so much they're yours okay well
just in time for Hispanic Heritage Month
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis upped the
game by sending two playing folds of
immigrants to the east coast Elite's
favorite vacation island Martha's
Vineyard Massachusetts I personally
think it's genius
wish that Governors like Ron DeSantis
and Greg Abbott would give Democratic
Governors and Mayors more of a heads up
because then that would expose the
hypocrisy of the Democrats which is they
don't want immigrants here either
he says I personally think it's genius
and what's great about it he's he's
obviously not being tongue-in-cheek he's
not being ironic his body language is
showing that he knows he's saying
something that he's not supposed to be
saying look I personally think it's
genius and then he gives that side eye
he kind of looks to the rest of the
panel and what's really amazing is no
one on that panel Twitches a muscle
they don't disagree they don't agree
they stay perfectly still
because they know they're not allowed to
agree okay if they if they do agree with
him they might get canceled
but they also know that he's right
and they know that DeSantis is right and
so they don't they don't want to agree
with it they don't want to disagree with
it
they're just absolutely Frozen there
but of course Charlemagne is correct
Ron DeSantis is absolutely crushing it
this is a strategy that a number of
people had been talking about on the
right actually Ted Cruz came up with the
strategy
he introduced a bill in the Senate
called the Stop The Surge act which said
we're going to open new ports of entry
and we're going to relocate the migrants
to Rehoboth Beach Delaware and Martha's
Vineyard and Nantucket and the Hamptons
and all over the place but because the
Republicans don't have the Senate
majority the cruise Bill didn't go
anywhere Then Greg Abbott started to try
to ship these migrants to Liberal cities
Promise New York City or Washington DC
or Chicago even the the migrants can
just kind of disappear these are major
American cities it causes some problems
but they can kind of paper over it it's
only when you send it to the really
really fine liberal enclaves when you
send it to Martha's Vineyard one of the
nicest beach towns in the country or
Cape Cod or the Hamptons or Republic
Delaware where Biden's from then you can
really see it okay and so it was Rhonda
Santos didn't come up with a strategy
but he did he did implement it and sort
of fine tune it
and perfect it and it's Genius of course
it's genius the Democrats have no way to
respond to it the best thing they can do
is go back to their regular old tricks
where they say this strategy whatever
the Republicans are doing it's dangerous
it's tantamount to murder they're
putting lives at risk
has the president reached out to any of
these Governors so here's the thing and
I was asked this question earlier today
I don't know why we would reach out to a
governor or Governors who are clearly
playing a political game right it is
something that they're doing not to find
a solution but to literally literally
put people's lives at risk
to literally put those lives at risk not
figuratively not metaphorically they are
literally putting people's lives at risk
by
sending them to Martha's Vineyard
one of the nicest safest places in the
country well putting their lives at risk
because let's say that one of the
Venezuelan illegal aliens one of the
migrants goes and gets a delicious
Martha's Vineyard lobster roll and let's
say while this migrant is sitting on the
beach enjoying that tasty Vineyard
lobster roll he discovers that he has a
shellfish allergy and he doesn't have
his EpiPen on him that hey look that his
life is at risk he's not going to be
getting lobster rolls in Del Rio or El
Paso that's for sure
of course Del Rio and El Paso and all
the Border towns are in every other way
much more dangerous to the migrants than
Martha's Vineyard or Rehoboth Beach
Delaware or Nantucket or anywhere else
but now it's putting lives at risk
unless we are misinterpreting what
Corrine Jean-Pierre is saying there
maybe what she means is not that the
migrants are at greater risk in Martha's
Vineyard than they are on the border
that's obviously Preposterous maybe what
she's saying is
that Rhonda Santos is putting the lives
of the people of Martha's Vineyard at
risk because the migrants are bringing
with them crime they're 100 of them are
bringing crime because they're they're
very presence in America is breaking one
of the most fundamental laws but
furthermore the only way that you cross
that border illegally is by paying off
the cartels these absolute Savage
animals some of the most
terrifying violent people on the planet
and then you go into debt to those
cartels and you gotta you've got to pay
back those debts when you're here in
America so yes it's true the migrants do
the ones who cross illegally bring a ton
of crime they bring a ton of violent
crime and they bring sex trafficking and
prostitution and all the rest of it so
yeah that's true Rhonda Santos I guess
is putting people's lives at risk in
Martha's Vineyard by bringing the
dangerous migrants to them fair enough
but it's the people of Martha's Vineyard
it's the liberals who are bringing the
migrants into America more generally
they're the ones who are putting the all
the Border Towns at risk and and
Americans generally at risk so okay if
this is a risk to people's lives
then stop allowing the cartels to
smuggle people across the border
either way either way the narrative
coming out of the White House does not
make sense I'm so glad you like that
clip now you've got to subscribe ring
that Bell get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
thank you